[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two
cigars yeah
yeah hey everybody Welcome to two Comics
two cigars uh I'm Tony V I'm Lenny Clark
yeah and we are happy to be doing this
we're actually we're happy to be doing
anything yeah I know they're smoking in
the middle of the day yeah and like it's
something we had to yeah it's like on
the clock say the wife where you going
I've got podcasts yeah I have to I have
to smoke a cigar and they they go wait a
second you can't smoke a cigar in the
middle of the day and you go of course
we can it's for work it's work it's work
it's a work cigar lots of people tune in
and watch this yes we gotta educate the
people on a couple of levels cigars and
comedy that's right that's what we do
that's cool yeah so what we're gonna do
when uh and uh anybody watching feel
free to light up at home too or if you
don't have a cigar just set something on
fire
it's uh it's all about the flame here
yeah you know so we're we're here at the
uh Studio 21 podcast Cafe which is above
two guys cigar shop in Salem New
Hampshire oh they also have shops in
Nashua and Manchester you can get them
uh online as well if you want to deal
with these folks nice people nice oh
very hospitable oh yeah yeah they gave
us these headphones yeah yeah water
water and that's and a cigar and a
warm-up cigar and yeah we had yeah we
this is this is uh what are we having
now what are we gonna do we're gonna
smoke uh this this is uh uh Sun grown
robusto Garofalo oh it's distributed in
the United States by United uh tobacco
okay who also provided the uh it's a guy
we smoke prey that was a United very
nice yeah that was the uh firecracker
that you can only get here yeah yeah
they're made especially for hair okay so
we're gonna cut these up all right all
right and I only know this from uh doing
other uh cigar shows here yep in Salem
that you're supposed to smell the foot
and see what you get I don't know if it
does any good but just smell it like
wine yeah
sniff it you snort it maybe a little
tobacco goes up your nose lick it always
look licking and then you take a dry
heat uh drawer huh
and see what you taste
I like what I think so it'll probably be
better if we uh light them yeah right
are you guys like yours
not that I don't appreciate that no but
sometimes
there you go thank you what a wonderful
item yeah and I'll tell you these are uh
a five-year age Cuban seed Sun grown
rapper which I'm assuming means it's
grown in the Sun and uh it's um the
filler is uh Cuban seed Nicaraguan and
it's finished in Bourbon barrels bourbon
bourbon barrels I assume again that they
take the bourbon out
well that's a waste I know someone's got
to have that bourbon right now there's
uh
a podcast called two guys two glasses of
bourbon somewhere somewhere that they're
doing that but they're not comedians no
no no it's just two guys drinking
bourbon so the barrel can be empty so
they can put these in there well that's
awful nice and this is uh this brand uh
is uh it's called Garofalo named death
the David Garofalo the owner of the shop
he had his own uh cigars made and Maria
yes good looks very nice yeah mine is
from Nicaragua yeah and you can have
some of the nicaraguans coming up across
the border bring some with them oh they
just put them in their pockets yeah yeah
that's good that seems to be the heaven
incentive for them to stay that's right
what do you have to offer us nicaraguans
and they'll say we got cigars and you go
come on
we like that you don't have any [ __ ]
wash station in your pants do you oh
cause that's illegal in California you
can't Africa I was talking to the chef
today [ __ ] what one of my friends and
now you can't have it in in Los Angeles
no why is that now it's illegal what is
Paraguay it's like a duck
yeah right yeah and I love it why I I
understand it's because in order to get
the Fire Guard to the point they force
feed the goose
wine
to expand its uh liver
in what feed
oh yeah
and they love it they enjoy it yeah yeah
and then then when you eat them they're
very happy for you yeah
is it the kind of thing where they just
take the liver and the duck goes on with
his life I mean the goose or or is it
like is it surgically removed like those
you know you hear those stories all the
time where a guy
wakes up in a tub full of ice in Mexico
and his kidneys missing yes yes I'd like
to do that someday
you want to take the kidney okay I'd
like to take a kidney yeah well you know
I I could probably use a kidney yeah I
mean they seem like it'd be good to have
just hanging around yeah I would not
like to be the guy in the top no no no
but you can get by without a kidney I'm
guessing wow right yeah yeah
there's just food for thought yeah
that's all you know things you think
about when you're having a good chicken
yeah there's something very relaxing
about cigars too oh my God I you know
I've uh I've had some medical problems
as you you have every time well okay 18
months ago I had a stroke and then I had
a minor heart attack then I had a major
heart attack and then I had five and a
half hours surgery for an ablation for a
flutter oh because I had the afib done
years ago and my doctor goes Lenny you
know no smoking to guys I go doc I don't
drink I don't do drugs I'm not chasing
things around right let me have a smoke
and relax
oh yeah
but hey look you know
it's like it's like my age now you know
I'm I'm getting up there in years and
say like I flip out and I murder someone
what are they gonna give me a life
sentence how long you think I can laugh
you know you'll get a murder most people
get eight years yeah right yeah so uh
and good behavior that's the average
yeah yeah it seems worth it yeah doesn't
it if you've got a bad neighbor yeah
absolutely yeah get out of my yard you
son of a [ __ ] yeah I mean from all the
stress from yelling at each other
eight years later and you gotta get off
earlier because uh uh good behavior yeah
because I'd be a model yeah
of course you know and um I mean yeah
it'd be worth it right there I think so
and would if you're in prison with your
uh join a gang or would you
um well I you know I've never been a
joiner yeah you know yeah I mean I I
think I'd have people send me money and
I'd find out who the toughest guy in his
joint was and I'd pay him as my
bodyguard oh you so you'd pay somebody
to protect me yeah that's a good idea
Yeah Yeah well yeah for all your prison
needs you can you can reach out to us
and we'll we'll tell you and uh if you
can't smoke in prison anymore I don't
know can you smoke in the yard maybe I
may think about it you're going away
yeah and you're in you're a heavy smoker
yeah and now they take it all away from
you that's gonna cost you yeah that yeah
yeah I want people happy oh yeah you
know what I mean so it's not like a
happy prisoner yeah I mean and uh here's
just a little tip at the top of the show
uh if you're in prison and you need a
weapon you know a lot of people will
grind something down make a shake yeah
but uh I also understand that three or
four cans of soda in a pillowcase
uh you know makes a a nice cudgel and
quarters yeah quarters I think that's
how they got Whitey bulge if I'm not
mistaken with quarters a a pillowcase
full of quarters yeah did a job on them
yeah we should tell folks we're both
from Boston so oh yes yes yeah uh Whitey
Bulger uh has uh
a lot of folklore around here is a good
guy but he was just the prick oh yeah
for what we understand yeah the folklore
was from people who are deadly afraid of
it what a good guy right he never killed
anyone in my family he used to buy
groceries for the neighborhood he was a
good man I did a movie in his one of his
uh liquor stores over at South Boston oh
yeah so what movie was that uh
uh salty oh yeah all right so uh I gotta
kill these guys and then I I beat this
guy up and they go and it was my buddy
Phil and I didn't want to beat him
because I liked him he's a good man but
you're acting
he says Mr [ __ ] really go ahead give it
to me so I put him through this lattice
work and punched his [ __ ] and they go
Lenny we don't own that lattice work
this is why he pulled this place and I
said good night
yeah you don't want to you didn't want
to I don't want to antagonize them you
know yeah even though we dressed in
women's clothes we should also tell
folks that not only are we uh comedians
but we both uh done some acting oh yes
and uh I think one of the most
interesting things uh about us is we've
both been uh killed on stage on film oh
yeah I've been killed a few times yeah
how how did you get it uh oh well in
Halloween yeah just recently yeah
recently yeah uh the number one movie in
the world last year yes Halloween girls
yeah and uh it killed me several times
yeah yeah I mean when he pulled me
through the window yeah I pretty much I
I got my throat sliced up from the glass
yeah and then when he sliced my throat
open uh with a light bulb uh no that was
my wife oh she got lived yeah it was in
the new movie
they know how to kill people yeah they
do yeah
and uh you know I uh it was it was a
very significant death
yeah it was good now you were killed a
Brotherhood right my brother I did a a
series called Brotherhood great show yes
and I was strangled
uh at the end of that season two right I
I have I must have an inviting neck yeah
because I was also killed in a movie
called uh
God Bless America but my goodness
and I was also strangled in that I love
that movie yeah that's where I played uh
uh pancake eating pedophile that was my
and and you know you you know here
picking you pedophile no not a whole lot
it's a there's a lot of alliteration in
there yeah you know it sort of rolls off
the tongue and I saw you I saw that film
and I saw you guys and I went wow would
I play a pedophile yeah absolutely it's
a job I'm acting I'm not I mean I mean I
I mean to the best of my knowledge you
know I hate kids anyway yeah yeah so so
but so it wouldn't do any damage but at
points in your life you know there are
moments in your life that you remember
and I uh at one point when my daughter
was in high school
it came up for some reason and they uh
went on my IMDb yeah and the the first
thing that came up was pancake eating
pedophile that's how that's how it's
listed in IMDb yeah Dad I've never been
prouder yeah
well this is quite yes it's a really
good cigar and you know I know you
sometimes like the the very dark and
yeah I like a heavy smoke and and I like
a mile yeah yeah yeah these are
somewhere in the middle yeah yeah David
knows what he's doing when he set us up
so uh the Garofalo
sun-grown robusto right very nice it's
very nice it's really a good cigar and
you can get them
you get them online if you want right
right or if you happen to be driving
through New Hampshire you could get
anything online I just found out all the
supportions at the abortions
you get a bush from Amazon and if you've
got Prime they'll come to the house and
do it really yeah and probably get a
five percent Kickback you probably will
especially if you're Prime yeah that's
come right to the house that's great
yeah you know I bet you they have you go
on YouTube right get a um you know like
a tutorial yeah on how to like a home
abortion yeah yeah I'm all for it yeah I
mean listen you know I mean who am I to
judge what a woman wants to do right
I've never been a judge in that
department before I'm not going to start
now no you know whatever one wants to do
let it do it you know I I have said this
I don't know if it's been said by anyone
else but I firmly believe this if it
were men having abortion yeah we'd be
able to get them at a bar like at happy
hour you could get it you could get we
could get out of the drive-through yeah
yeah you could just go into any Pub or
Tavern or or club and go Hey listen uh
can I can I get some chicken wings and a
beer and I'm just going back have an
abortion I'll be out in a minute yeah
drive through how about a spicy chicken
sandwich and in the bush yeah it would
be like the special God yeah six
abortions you get the seventh one free
for free yeah and would be having them
every other week oh God yeah yeah you
know so listen we shouldn't get high and
mighty about stuff like that who am I
the judge what people don't know okay I
was not put on this planet to judge no I
don't know about anybody else but if I
did play a judge yeah I wouldn't wear
pants
like like they do with the with the
joker
the Scottish the Scottish guys with the
Kilts yeah yeah yeah they swinging like
a gate on there yeah guilty guilty
that's it that's all you need right
um
and you're still doing stand-up we both
do stand-ups that's what we do right
yeah yeah yeah I mean I was like you
know it's very very hard now because of
the political correct everybody's
political whoa whoa yeah if I was a new
kid coming up I'd be the filthiest
dirtiest unwoke person alive but I'm too
old right now
we've had our day we've had our run and
we did all that oh yeah when they
weren't uh cell phones yeah I mean if
they had cell phones when you and I were
coming up we'd both be in jail oh we
would we'd be doing that yeah right now
yeah
um yeah I find you know I don't work
uh you know particularly
uh unwoke right you know what I mean
it's not my thing I don't push buttons
right per se but I do do some stuff that
I find now if you just say a word people
are ready to just be upset by a word I
do a joke about uh
lesbians yeah well I love yeah I'm a big
fan I've I've been on the websites yeah
uh it's uh but you say the word and and
people just shut down right you know
what I mean and it's I'm not making fun
of lesbians no I'm making fun of my knit
with friends who don't understand right
a particular issue how about the guys
who think they can change
[Laughter]
well people think it's a choice of
people go when someone turns gay you
know no one turns gay you're gay you're
not a lady asked me the other day they
say you gay I said lady I'm not even
happy come on I mean but but but you
know this is a great subject yeah I'd
also find the older I get it doesn't you
know whatever preconceived notions I had
as a as a youth you know you gotta
unlearn that like gay doesn't seem so
bad to me now as I age what's the
difference who I'm not having sex with
exactly you know what I mean and I'm
about two years away from not giving a
[ __ ] about anything
so okay so let's be honest we're about
two years away from not remembering
anything oh yeah oh I already have that
problem with the stroke yeah but you
know like now uh we are into the process
of pronouns pronouns yes
is very confusing yeah yeah yeah I mean
I'm still trying to figure out what a
dangling participle is yeah I can't deal
with problem so I'm on a set and uh this
this guy walks by you know in the dress
and the earrings and the hair man yeah
yeah and I go Excuse Me Miss because I
want to know what next thing we're doing
and my buddy punches like that's not a
message she said dress it turns around
you got a ZZ Top bit yeah yeah and I
said hello person you know yeah because
I I because I don't know what they're
called yeah you don't know so I said
what would you prefer to be called and
the person say I want to be called them
them yeah say them isn't that a
pluralist church she said what do you
prefer to be called I go thus why on
Earth do you want to be called us
because you're them of us we're a badge
I'll call you whatever's on the badge my
good God there's a guy Tony yeah who's
he was a male swimmer yeah not doing
real good decides to swim with the girls
yeah he's ripping up the NC double H
he's killing him I mean he's swimming he
might go to the Olympics and I I've won
I don't know how you feel about this I
don't think it's fair yeah
you don't think that
just because a person identifies as the
other sex
he's got a dick he's using it as a
runner it's not fair so at least it's
keeping him straight as well he's not
varying it down the lanes stay in your
lane yeah does he have uh
uh breast did he did he go that far see
now that now you're in a weird area yeah
yeah well I mean if you want to be a
girl yeah you get the operation right
the law but took off for me yes and you
do that and then you're a woman then
you're a woman if you're a woman who
wants to be a guy yeah you of course
have the adedictomy right that's all
medical you don't think yeah I
understand uh you know what there seems
to be a business there where you could
just swap them off you know what I mean
when you take someone's a dick yeah you
just save it because someone's gonna
want it
it could be money yeah that's like a
Mexican hot tube yeah yeah you know you
just keep them on ice and someone goes
I'd like to have a penis you go well
this is our selection take whichever one
you'd like yeah oh you know Tony yeah
now that you mention that you know I I
do a lot of charity work for the Mass
General and yeah God loved them man and
I did it out of goodness in my house not
not looking for anything yeah yeah but
uh raised a lot of money for them no
sure honey we'd like to do something for
you I says
well you know sometimes late at night my
eyes are drooping you know and I I had
to read and they go oh we can fix that
in the office Bing Bang Boom I said well
we ought to do something special I go
well you are the only hospital I know of
that does penis transplants oh I think
I'd like a new penis right why not why
wouldn't right come on I mean so I'm
over there and they're looking at my
eyes and then they said would you like
to go to the cockatorium I don't know
what they call it but there's a place
where they have all these penis they
have they have a selection a selection
of course I want to it's like lobsters
yeah at a restaurant yeah yeah so I went
in and I said oh I want that red one on
the wall they so Mr collect that's a
fire extinguish that's okay but I think
I think I'm gonna go with with a big
black one oh that's a yeah yeah yeah
because I saw the selection
that could that could be a money maker
yeah you know because if I had a giant
penis yeah I would not wear pants that
why would you great and people said let
me you're not bad saying I forgot you
know the stroke I forget things
yeah but look at the size of this thing
that'd be good I could I could get a job
in Cirque du Soleil yeah
um I think we're about
I don't know I'm gonna say six or eight
years
to being able to
you know just interchange Parts you know
what I mean like yes like Snap-on Tools
now you get a drill and you just yeah
yeah you know you can have a dress penis
right you know you could have one for
the weekends workout penis workout penis
so it doesn't get in the way when you're
on this right on the StairMaster
whatever or in a bike seat oh yeah you
know we don't want to get caught in the
chains if you're back on a big yeah you
know what you want to get caught in a
chain of course
what happened it's no good it's no good
we're here to help the problems of the
world that's all I'm saying
that is all I'm saying so this cigar
Tony yeah uh for those who want to know
it's uh a five times 54 ring yeah it's
five inches by the the gauge is 54
around I like a big ring I do too yeah I
like between like a 54 and a 60 I think
I've had uh
some that are 70 but that's just it's
just too much a 70 ring is too much but
this is a nice size yeah this is a
perfect size yeah yeah a Churchill is a
little too thin for me right I don't
like it's like 48 I think yeah uh and
that's a little bit too thin I like a
like a 54 to 60. I think that's the
perfect thing unless like the
firecracker was smoking the little one
that I like the little one great when
you're waiting for the wife in the car
yeah yeah well or you know uh some of
them are known as dog walkers oh you
know it's like when you take the dog for
a walk and then when this guy's done
we're done come on
I've done my business I gotta go you
know I think it's pretty incredible that
a lot of people with dogs are very nice
people yeah and the dog you know they
pick it up with a little bit you have to
yeah uh but now people are [ __ ] in
the street yeah and they're not picking
up after themselves no no the dog's
going what the hell is this what
this looks like human faces right who's
gonna pick this up right and I'm getting
I'm getting my nose rubbed in it yeah
what are you gonna do to this guy
yeah I don't you know the the whole uh
you know pooping dog thing you know I
live in the city and oh yeah uh as do
you and and uh you know it's it's like
uh you gotta tiptoe around it's like a
Minefield right you don't know where you
can step over with it right but not from
the dogs not from the dogs you know the
dogs I find most most of the dog on a
very very nice very responsible very
respectable people yeah they scoop it up
with the thing you know I mean I'm often
I put the people yeah I mean when I was
in Colombia I was in the Columbia South
America and I'm driving to the set and
what were you doing down there I was
filming um uh gee the movie yeah it was
a movie called the Revenge of samax it
was uh oh it was based on a series
yeah Burn Notice Burn Notice okay yes so
we're driving to the set and I see these
signs these big big rounds signs with a
guy
[ __ ] on the street in an accident
yeah what is that he goes oh that's the
no [ __ ] Zone and I go what oh yeah
two blocks up the street
right there [ __ ] right there well thank
God he wasn't back there yeah well they
do them spank them or or push them off
[ __ ] dipping right I got cow tipping my
daughter with paper that's all you do oh
yeah and you can do it right from the
car oh yeah I buy them open the window
hey
of course my god of course yeah but now
you travel we've both traveled
extensively too best place you've ever
been
um I really liked Barbados yeah until we
started going through a robe is
fantastic Tony one of my favorite we
could get on the plane right now be
there before Oh my God you know I tell
anybody who cares about this if you ever
don't see me yeah for like three or four
years and you go whatever happened to
that guy he's in a room he's in a robot
under a Palapa yeah smoking a cigar
right and not caring about a [ __ ]
thing now do you know we've had many a
good smoke yeah under Palapas down there
yeah sometimes we get out and really
tear it up oh yeah yeah oh I've been
with you where you look like a candle oh
yeah you put like uh 10 40 weight oil on
you and then just people died for this
oil oh yeah I'm gonna use it oh yeah
yeah I looked at you you were so shiny
one day oh yeah it looked like you had
been casting wax yeah yeah I really
enjoyed that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I was putting more oil on it it was
just going into me right now we had a
tan inside yeah oh yeah inside out well
you're not tanning at that point you're
you're bait you're basically basing
yourself and and frying yeah yeah and
with this global warming twice the ten
half the time you know don't be afraid
of it let's look at the positive sides
of global warming
ugly people look better sure I'll let
them know yeah
last time I was in Aruba and as you say
we you know we have had many a fine
cigar uh oh yeah on the beach there and
no one cares that much no one no no no
one bothers you remember remember the
couple I thought was going to bother us
yeah and I went over and I I dusted off
their feet yeah yes and they said wow
that's awful nice here I said oh Jesus
wash feet I I clean once you know what
you need to know about my friend Lenny
Clark here is that when he goes to the
beach he brings a brush with them that's
a beach brush
uh and he will uh uh that when he comes
out of the water he lets the sand dry
and then brushes off his feet so you
don't get any sand on your Jay's lounge
and you're on the chase Lounge
completely saying this tip I picked up
from Elvis yeah yeah
he had a brushed person he had a brush
guy well I'm not that big yeah but also
Lenny is so magnanimous he will walk up
and down the beach offering to brush
other people's feet yeah and I brushed
his Venezuelan guy's wife's feet yeah
yeah excuse me I asked you might have to
marry her yeah so can I can I do your
wife's feeding us I guess I do the flea
and she goes oh honey this is fantastic
look there's no sand on my towel and I
see the guy the next day at dinner at
lunch yeah and he buys me lunch and I
said hey that was you didn't have to do
that he goes it was so nice you go
there's the brush
I gave the brush again and it's
exclusive Beach brush the last time this
is the point last time I was in Aruba I
was there
and I was smoking under the Palapa and
this woman came over to me and she it's
the first time it's ever happened to me
she says to me she goes uh has anyone
ever busted your balls about smoking on
the beach and I go not to write this
very second
and then the husband just fell out
laughing yeah he goes That's the best
answer I've ever heard and she goes no
no because he wants to smoke when I go
light up I'll give you one well you know
when we were down there with the pilots
they were lighting up everywhere yeah we
can smoke yeah you can't smoke in
California on the beach I went out on
the beach one morning and I was smoking
with Dennis yeah and we barely lit up
and four-wheelers came up surrounded us
yeah it said there's no smoking on any
part of California's Seashore and I said
really I said yeah I said well I'm
Mexican he went ah they walked away
loophole yeah
right there right well I was on I was in
now you you mentioned Dennis Dennis
Larry and you did you've done many
projects with him yeah yeah old friend
of ours and uh most notably it was uh
rescue me oh God yeah well you played
Uncle Teddy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was fun what was that like it was
great uh and you know I got the murder
of a guy yeah always fun I I've off
somebody on yeah
well I'll tell you a story about that
we when you work with him you get picked
up and taken to the set and everything
and so uh I was the first pickup of the
day and I said to the teams to I hopped
up with him you know I was sitting in
the front and we pick up these two guys
you know one might have minor actors but
right yeah Dave players yeah but short
they played because they want that you
know anyway so they're talking about all
the movies they've been at yeah it must
have been three three thousand moves I
love that I worked with this guy I
worked with this woman and I'm up front
with a I'm up so I didn't get in the van
and I go I don't boys they don't even
say hi yeah yeah yeah so now we pull
over to get child's turning perhaps one
of the greatest actors terrific one nice
guy too so I get out and I put down a
stool and I help Charlie get up into the
front seat and they go who's that like
it's one of the greatest actors you've
ever seen in your life that's child's
learning oh so then I get back and I'm
sitting way in the back now just
listening
and we pull up to the center and we go
I know the kid goes almost a clock I'm
so sorry I didn't realize it was you I
said don't worry about it pal I'm about
to kill you in two hours anyway shot him
dead two and a half that was the best
acting I ever did because I wasn't
acting you wanted to kill him yeah yeah
yeah yeah I love stuff like that where
people you know give you the hi-hat oh
until they think they know you or you
you're somebody yeah right I did uh I
had the uh pleasure doing the Great
American Comedy Festival
a few years back it's out in uh Iowa
Indiana Oh Indiana okay Johnny Carson's
hold right right right right is it
Indiana yes it is yeah I think so yeah
North oh North it's North Fork somewhere
right it's in the midwest which if
you're from the east coast of the West
Coast it's just one of the places in the
middle that you fly over yeah that fly
yeah the flyover country it all looks
the same yeah like you drive for hours
and you see you know Subway sub shops
and that's the town that's it that's all
they got yeah but I was doing this uh
festival and there was you know a guy of
some note and I'm not going to out
anybody but he was you know acting like
he was uh you know better than us the
whole time and by the end of the week
the whole thing became much like this
would be sitting around smoking a cigar
after the show outside and you know
laughing but letting this guy be off on
his own you know pretending to be
important or whatever and then he sees
us do sets and we're the talk of the
festival a couple of us you know older
guys blah blah blah and then like day
four he comes over and he goes hey is
this chair taken and I go too [ __ ]
late buddy
I know that chair was open four days ago
too not now your ship is sailed my
friend oh yeah you gotta move it along
hey we're about halfway through and
according to our sheet of paper yes we
have to talk about uh the cigar again
okay whoa and I don't no problem and I
say have to but I want to because I'm
really enjoying in the hell out of this
Tony so am I yeah I mean I really love
the I love the flavor I love the draw
everything it's just a good second yeah
and right and for me who likes a heavy
smoke this is this is smooth but it's
got a lot of flavor right uh and again
let me remind folks that we're smoking
uh Garofalo sun-grown robusto it's a
5x54 ring gauge and it's made uh uh by
in the prodomo factory and pedona was a
great a great house for cigars right you
know what I mean so they know what
they're doing in the in the cigars it's
a Garofalo and it's a gravel made for
specifically for two guys right and
that's two guys the number two
Guys Smoke Shop don't put two guys
smoking each other yeah no that's a
different website entirely yeah I'm told
if you put the two guys right
something's going to come up on your
screen that you can't unsee oh yeah and
I makes me want to see it but I don't
know if I want to go down that alley no
at this point no but uh halfway through
I'm saying this is uh this is a great
cigar oh fantastic you would not be
unhappy smoking this no at all and and I
like it like you know I'm a mild cigar
smoker yeah and this is you know it's a
step above what I know yeah yeah yeah
but it's not but it's more it's not
overpowered you know I mean your first
experience yeah with a Cuban cigars yes
tell me yeah well you know Cubans
were the the standard for a while
because and they had the law about them
because for 60 some odd years we
couldn't get them exactly and I believe
that when the Embargo started uh you
know in the 60s yeah that that was every
every bit is true that Cuban was the
gold standard of cigars but when Fidel
Castro took over Cuba everybody grabbed
their seeds and went elsewhere yes and
in that 60 years they have learned how
to cultivate and make better cigars
absolutely you know so I think there are
some nicaraguans that now smoke every
bit as good as a Cuban cigar but it
still has this Mystique about it like if
we go to Aruba or overseas and you can
get a cube and people go you you know
you can get a cube and I go I don't
necessarily need a cube right you know I
I like I like what I like and uh uh this
is right up there with that is is what
I'm saying well my first experience with
Cuban cigars on my own I was uh I was
doing the show Lenny and yeah Money Was
No Object oh yeah you have flew into
Detroit to do a show and I said to my
wife we're right across the border from
Canada let's go get some cubes so we
drive over there and uh a lot of cigar
stores and they Cuban we sell Cubans big
signs and they saw me coming I went in
and I bought maybe like a 500 box of
Cuban cigars and uh we smoked them back
into the country of course and um I had
them out at my house and I had the
Riders over the house and I was smoking
and they said what is this a Cuban's a
guy I go yeah why it sucks and I said
you know you're right yeah I go they saw
me coming yes so I I I hate it yeah I
was very upset yeah I think there's a
lot of bootlegs too yes yes yes pohiba I
think is the most bootlegged cigar there
is on the planet yeah you know what I
mean everybody comes back from somewhere
with hey I got some Cuban cahibas like I
know yeah no no no it looks like a tree
branch that's been wrapped with a yellow
label right yeah I I think they saw you
coming most expensive is the guy you
ever smoked uh we one time at the matte
light shootout
uh somebody bought me which I heard you
killed that I am a terrible shot uh
usually with the gun
yeah yeah we've shot together many times
and if at the end sometimes you're just
going bang Bang Yeah I've been looking
not that bad people call it skeet
shooting I call it pointing a gun in the
air and pulling the trigger right and
because that's basically what I did uh
and if I hit something it was only
because the bird you know happened to
fly in front of my my my
gun oh and sometimes you would be so
upset oh I get so mad but this time this
I was lights out man I I had to shoot
you were the best on the tape yeah I
shot about 60 or 70 percent uh we had
one uh one station we had four reports
and I got all four Birds then you got
the the little I got the Rabbit running
across the ground I I you know that's
another thing you know I'm not a big gun
guy yeah I don't mind guns
I love God yeah I know you don't
um but I like to shoot a gun I mean I've
taken weapons training I know how to you
know for various TV shows or whatever
right and I I enjoy the process of
shooting skeet but you know but I'm not
a big into the big gun culture but I
have to say if you ever get a chance to
shoot skeet you should oh my God it's a
lot of fun it's driving it's riding
around in a golf cart blowing [ __ ] up
yeah and we do it for the kids for the
kids it's all for the kids now it's
better than golf oh much you know
because we get roped into [ __ ] golf
tournaments all the time and we play
with these guys who are serious and they
just go oh for them why can't we have
the shotgun now yeah that just you know
I you know someone tee off I'd shoot the
ball right out of the air
no problem yeah yeah so tell them to get
that one your most expensive it's a guy
oh so at one uh time after matlight
shootout they have Rolling Stones
trailer with the humidor in it and
somebody one of the pr people bought me
a 90 dollar uh Opus X and it was uh I'm
gonna say it was 10 or 11 inches long
and probably a 54 6. oh nice yeah it was
it was it was massive I mean it felt a
little uncomfortable in my mouth you
know
but that I think I believe that to be
the most expensive cigar I've ever had
okay
me
I'm doing Lenny yeah and there was a guy
who used to come we treat the the show
One Church is straight through and then
we'd break for dinner and then we'd
shoot the other show where we'd do
pickups and everything right and put it
all together so there was a guy who used
to come around with a briefcase and he
looked like kind of a shady character
and he was with all the producers yeah
and after a few weeks I went out to be
with them and they were smoking cigars
he opened up this Briefcase full of
cigars right so he says let me I have a
cigar I'd like you to try I said okay so
he opens up the big [ __ ] cigar and I
light it up and I hmm hmm oh very good
he goes you know that's a guy costs 1100
I go what I'm not paying for this year
no no it's a gift it's a gift relax it's
the same time eleven hundred dollars a
stick now this was the cigar that Castro
gave to the dignitaries that came
it was his cigar like someone took it
away from cat no no no no this is these
are the these are the guys that he had
specially made for when they had uh
dignitaries oh yeah yeah ambassadors
yeah or anyone Castro really like they
they would smoke they said casserole so
and what Castro quit smoking right well
the people who made these guys just they
left and they brought them with them and
a box costs like twenty thousand dollars
you know and I'm saying oh my and I
smoked it and I gotta tell you it was
okay it was all right I like this better
and I actually like this
garofalo's sun-grown robusto yeah as
much as the eleven hundred dollars there
are a lot of things I think people get
into pricing I was out the dinner one
night with my wife was our anniversary
so we went to a nice day my anniversary
today oh happy anniversary I love you
honey yeah uh that's nice how many years
26 in a row wow that's some that's some
kind of a record for you oh yeah the
first one was just eight the second one
was a matter of weeks but we were out to
dinner and my wife ordered a 70 dollar
bowl of pasta it was truffle yeah oh
yeah truffles involved with this or that
uh and uh
you know it's your anniversary so you
don't say anything but you go [ __ ] 70
dollars for all the pasta and at the end
I go how was it she goes that's pretty
good I go no no no that's gonna be the
best
you should have had an orgasm having
that pasta that's you know the balls on
people that to do that we go out to
dinner I'm down in uh the Ritz-Carlton
in South Beach and it's fabulous yeah so
the guy there who doesn't work there
anyway he gave me a great deal in a room
yeah so let me take you and your your
girlfriend out to dinner me and Mike we
we take them out to dinner and they said
and of course we have this delicious
pasta with the with the truffles bring
it out right guy comes out with a scale
and he starts slicing yeah yeah and put
it on the scale yeah and throw them in I
go mom
you know that's gonna go guys it was
like 300 right but it's all a try I said
I didn't know that yeah I never do that
again yeah but it was oh yeah well I one
time I did an event in New York City at
a place called Le Cirque oh yeah this
was one of those oh God yeah of course
in the whole place uh my buddy uh Todd
English yeah getting restaurateur the
Year award from Bon Appetit magazine and
uh he asked me to come down and give him
the award and what'd you do and well
you know I made a shambles of the place
oh yeah you know and I started [ __ ]
on them because one of the things one of
the the
uh appetizers they they offer is pig's
feet and truffle
you know on yeah and I go and I go isn't
it's a pig who finds the Truffle isn't
it they have special words yeah yeah
that's a hell of a way to thank somebody
for finding listen listen you found a
truffle can we have one of your feet
[Music]
good pig can we have one ears did you
try it yeah no no no have you ever tried
to pig's feet good no no there you go we
heard from the Shepherd by the words I
don't even want it at me but this one
particular time I'll kill that duck boy
I'll kill it you know I not even shoot
it I [ __ ] strangle it yeah I'd sneak
up on it yeah
yeah but uh I did one of the most
Unthinkable things you can do is at all
the restaurants oh the big ones big huge
restaurants The Grateful Dead was there
Harold Ramis was there you know blah
blah it was all this thing and I decided
in the middle of this event I was going
to have a a pizza delivered to the
Cirque
and they go oh you got to clear that
with Alphonse and I go oh Who the hell's
Alpha he goes well you know he's the
maitre d he's the he's the top guy so
you know and this guy had a broomstick
so far Pizzazz it was sticking out of
his mouth you know and uh so I go hey
Alphonse I I I want to have a pizza
delivery and he goes very good sir I go
uh yeah you know maybe three or four he
goes very good sir and I go he goes uh
when would you like your pizzas
delivered I go I don't know you know
it's gonna be a timing thing you know he
goes very good perhaps I'll wiggle my
nose
you know so so I I arrange it with this
guy to have dominoes come in and deliver
pizzas to leserk yeah and and uh so I
walk away I grease them and I walk away
and he still hasn't broken character
right you know it's like I'm gonna be
damned if I'm gonna let this guy get the
best of me so I go back I go Alphonse
you know it's a gag I know it's listen
and I know what this place is and it's
just gonna be a funny you know gag about
you know it's the most expensive man in
the world
and I have a joke about it and and he
goes yes sir it's very funny
ah
and he'd never never once and we had the
pizza delivered and then I had the kid I
told her the kid who delivers the pizza
I go uh do you know any jokes he goes I
I know like some you know joke jokes I
go go up on stage and and tell a couple
of jokes and I'll pass the hat for you
so I got all these people I passed the
hat to get him a tip right kid walked
away with a 350 tip oh my God yeah yeah
yeah and this was the day before uh 9
11. it was September 10th wow uh
2011 well 2001 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah that that always stuck out in
my mind for those two reasons got a
cigar story about 9 11. I'm sorry you
didn't let me know before that because I
was in town we were filming right I know
the job or something and the towers went
down first one went down then I'm
watching on TV the other one goes down I
go that's it I'm going down there I'm
gonna help out so we're outside there's
no Subways no cabs yeah buses nothing
the towns stopped so I got about three
bucks and I rent a mountain bike and I'm
about 370 pounds yeah
and I ride right down right down to the
Cross Bronx Expressway you know all the
way down yeah and I pull up to the to
where the cops to stop you and I go hey
look I'm here to help out here sir you
can't help out like look I'm a big guy I
can move [ __ ] I could save lives and Go
sir it's a crime scene and again next to
me goes that's what they told me too kid
I looked it's Jimmy Gandolfini no they
was there too so we had a smoke we had a
smoke and watch something crazy yeah I
was in New York you know for that for
that too and the last thing I said to my
wife before cell service went out was
I'm going down to see if I can help
right yeah right I know we weren't going
anywhere but in a typical New York
Fashion too uh I I decided they called
up they go we assume you're staying
longer we're at the W Hotel you know and
I go uh don't count on it and I run down
to see if I can rent a car and there's a
big long line oh and I think I got the
last car in Manhattan and I took it one
way back to Boston but there were people
getting cars and guys were gonna drive
to Ohio and drop someone off and then go
to Texas and you know everyone just
wanted to get out of town get out of
Dodge and so in New York they go up and
get your car in a in a high-rise uh
parking lot or whatever and you're
waiting for it and now this is all this
Mayhem there's death deathly silence
because of what's going on and my car's
just coming down and uh
um I'm waiting to get in and then I hear
a guy go oh my God and everybody freezes
because you know we don't know what's
happening right he goes did you see the
ass on that bro
and I go ah America is going to be just
fine speaking of brunch we're beautiful
yeah uh I'm sure if we must yeah I'm
shooting rescue me and uh and watch this
girl who was a a player for the week
and she's gorgeous I mean beautiful face
beautiful yeah beautiful everything and
uh she comes up to me says excuse me uh
it's Dennis around they go nobody will
be I said uh are you on the Shelf she
goes yes we did a big scene last night I
said oh that's great and uh she bent
over to get something out of her bag
yeah and I'm looking at her house oh my
God I turn around 60 people on the crew
members the rest Austin and I said yeah
excuse me I said are you an ass model
and she said no why I said because you
have an amazing ass and I think you'd be
a fantastic asthma he says really I turn
around and she turns around all the guys
are looking like so that is what he goes
what are you doing I said I met uh I'm
Italian she's terrific he goes come here
let me ask you this what are you doing I
said Dennis she's got the most fabulous
ass I've ever seen on a woman in my life
and he says okay well when you're
through frankensteining your perfect
chick could we shoot the scene
something you couldn't get away with now
no by the way oh God you can't get away
with anything you know every everyone's
offended I'm offended I'm offended good
God Almighty you know we don't there's
not a malicious opponent not none of
them I'm good well if anybody ever heard
conversations we have in private we
would be put away
but I know your heart and you know my
yes yes yes and we don't have a we don't
have an evil thought about anybody no we
will say anything to anybody correct but
we don't care no right and when we go
out to dinner the group of us yeah we
take our phones and yeah turn them off
yes and put them down yeah you don't
want any it's like a guy named Witnesses
it's horrible I right now I'm gonna do
something uh that I am a fan of and a
lot of people don't know about this and
we're going to teach if if people are
still watching yeah we're going to teach
them something right now this is called
degassing oh yeah well you take a flame
foreign
and what I've been told is to get rid of
all the impurities that might have come
from the first half of the cigar and
then your next draw will be like you
just lit it all right
I've seen you do it
and I have to say I'm still a fan of it
I just bought like through a straw
with the flame on it apparently
there you go
yeah
now let me let me see what you think
it's pretty good right it's better than
good yeah that's great so if you're with
us now you just learned something yeah
you know
that's where I'd like to end the show
but we got nine more minutes all right
well we can we can fill yeah well we got
plenty to talk about I'll talk to you
all all [ __ ] day if like if I could
oh I know our lives don't let us do that
no no no they they grown men like us
they you know my wife often says that
she goes you know grown men don't
usually have friends like you have I go
good I don't I don't want I don't want
them to have my friends they couldn't
handle my friends oh no yeah because you
know some of the people that that we run
with
we we have them for our entertainment
yes oh yeah yeah I mean oh I often say
this we could if I had to pay for the
amount of entertainment I've given
myself yeah and and my comedy career I
couldn't afford it right it's just the
most entertaining thing every day is
some kind of new foolishness that we
have to deal with even at our Advanced
days people say well they ask us all the
time what's it feel like you know when
you when you crush a crowd they're
standing a chair area the second best
feeling in the world
and of course someone
tell your story I don't want to talk to
you about it you know that was very what
a dickassing degassing yeah yeah yep I'm
a you I'm a huge fan of that I do it uh
all the time what's the uh uh most
memorable show you got the comic come oh
yeah home coming up yep that's on the
12th of November yeah my most memorable
show
without a doubt has to be Boston Strong
and I'll tell you why they got all the
biggest rock groups ever came out of
Boston Harold Smith you know uh Boston
yeah uh a couple of terrific groups
and they had
Dane Cook yeah okay and uh Sweeney and
Steve Wright
and I wasn't asked to do it
and I was I was really hurt yeah I said
Jesus well because when it comes to the
Boston Book comedy it's you and then
everybody else I mean I have no problem
saying that well there would be no
Boston comedy if not for you because I
was out of my mind yeah yeah and you
still are oh yeah yeah and I don't
consider myself funny I'm insane yeah
which is good yeah because I've managed
to make a career out of course so I
called Stephen Tyler in Japan and I wake
him up right and I go hey because I used
to open pharaohsman so hey Steve it's
Lenny what's up he goes you just woke me
up plenty I go well you don't need much
sleep you're older now so he says I I
didn't get asked to do the comics uh the
Boston Strong show he goes what he goes
that's ridiculous so he caused on law
Don Law calls me the next day she's
Lenny I am terribly sorry it was
oversight on my part forgive me would
you please consider doing it I go don
I'm beyond thankful I'll do whatever you
want I'll host he goes no no no I think
Dane's going to host this and I said
okay all right well I'll go and we'll do
a set right so I went and I the girl who
who was killed uh I went out with her
aunt she was my girlfriend in high
school and I didn't realize that and so
I went to the family's house and I did
my set in the living room and because it
was it was it could have went either way
right and they said Lenny it's
hysterical do it you know and I wanted
to have you know check with them first
so I went out and I got a standing on
the boss of God and it wasn't my show
right but to have a standing oh that's
that at the Boston Garden I mean that
was one of the greatest drills of my
life yeah you know so yeah that was you
well
me I just recently got to uh open called
Bill Burr I had Fenway Park yeah oh
pardon me and to anyone still listening
again I didn't leave Lenny that way to
get to this story no no no no I'm glad
it's here but I got to do Fenway Park in
front of 35 000 people because of Bill
Burr but but you are technically the
first comedian that ever performed yes
at Fenway yes but it had nothing to do
with me doesn't matter it's just
happened but it was you know people go
was it nerve-wracking is it this and I
go leading up to who it was but when
when you get on stage we do what we do
yeah and there's I'm nervous every time
yeah every time if you're not you
shouldn't be doing I couldn't agree more
I tell the young kids that right you're
still nervous like I'm nervous now yeah
because you don't know because
every night is a crap shoot in our
business right you don't know who's in
front of you you don't 35 000 people you
know there's gonna be one lie yeah well
we ran into that ass call if you
remember correctly
sweet Dash we were doing a golf
tournament that's right and I you know I
don't crow about things and blah blah
and I was being very low-key about him
people had mentioned it and uh you
introduced me to some guy yeah I I try
to get him off my back yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you you say to him and
this is the kind of thing that's the
comedian's headset yeah and you say to
him oh Tony just opened for Bill burrow
bird Fenway Park and he looked at me he
goes oh you were the opening act and I
go yeah he goes so what do you like a c
plus comedian with a lot of friends and
I look at the guys
goodbye and oh my God you know my
response is yeah it's better than being
an A plus [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and I guess that
kid is somewhat of a committee wants to
he wants to be a comedian that's that's
a good way to get to get in yeah but
that's one of those things that you know
you go I don't know maybe there's some
truth to that I don't know she's but but
it would that that was another worldly
experience it was it was pretty good
so Arrowhead well you got another one
when you opened for Jerry Lewis remember
oh I did the Palladium
in London England yeah I was on tour
with uh my friend Bobcat Goldthwait our
friend and uh uh Jerry Lewis was getting
honored at this thing uh it was a drug
rehab thing called Turning Stone and I
wasn't even on the show I wasn't
supposed to be on the show but I had
been doing sets around London and uh it
was going pretty well and there was all
these you know uh big comedians there
Paul provenza and you know all these
guys emo Phillips and uh Jim Gaffigan
was there and Goldthwait and then a
bunch of British comics and and uh it
comes time to bring out Jerry Lewis and
the MC comes off with this I'm back on
stage with the sick look on his face and
he goes uh I don't know how to tell you
this but uh Mr Lewis has become unwell
he will not be performing
and then the guy just sort of shut down
and Goldthwaite in his uh in him being
him literally runs on stage pushes him
off you know because the guys like
floundering right on stage and uh uh
Goldthwaite does a few minutes and and
people are sort of laughing still and
and he just looks out in the audience
I'm in row two and he goes hey Tony you
want to do a set
and I go yeah why not yes so I get I get
up out of my I get up out of my seat I
walk backstage and go away uh steps of
the mic again he goes ladies and
gentlemen you've seen uh two plus hours
of amazing comedy I can't think of a
better way to close this show than with
a guy you have no [ __ ] idea who he is
he goes please welcome my good friend
Tony V
and I walk out on stage a Jerry Lewis's
band is there they play me on you know I
walk to the mic and I go well I already
got a story to tell you guys will let me
know how it ends
and I got a huge round of applause the
set went great and I ended up closing
the Palladium instead of Jerry Lewis and
if I'm not mistaken wow we just did it
right right to an hour
yeah we got to rate the cigar now that's
our producer uh Ed Sullivan there's a
crack yeah produce he's the best you
know he used to have a big show on CBS
yes things didn't work out yeah yeah you
know once uh Plate's spinning oh lost
favor yeah that bet show went to hell uh
anyway so we're gonna rate this a guy I
gotta say I enjoyed this cigar and I
guess the rating system we are going to
use is uh would you none would you not
buy it again oh no would you buy one
more would you buy five or would you buy
a box hmm
what are your thoughts
I would buy five more right now yeah I I
gotta say this
I'd go box really yeah I'd smoke these
on a regular basis Yeah well yeah well
because it's a step it's a step up well
plus Dave gravel gave these to us yeah I
loved it yeah and and they're a good
cigars
they're a really good cigar and again
it's the uh it's the sun grown robusto
it's uh Garofalo you can see that right
right there they're really they're made
by United in the prodomal as distributed
by United cigar made in the prodomo
factory and I gotta say Dave what's what
do these go for 10 bucks this is a ten
dollars I apologize box box yeah 100 I I
can't say enough good stuff about this
oh God there's gonna be like 40 bucks a
stick I really did yeah in Vegas you get
260. oh yeah it's unbelievable they
screw you in Vegas yeah so I buy a box
I'll go to Vegas I can buy a house
that's all you got to do all right
fabulous that was great thank you thank
you Lenny uh uh and I I want to thank uh
Robert Kelly love Kelly who uh you know
set this whole thing up and this is on
his uh an Irish Affair it was his
partner and all this and uh hopefully
you enjoyed it if you're not just keep
your [ __ ] mulch up known once they
hear me